you may have images that work fine on a
low resolution desktop monitor that
looked terrible on a high DPI display
not a problem we'll just save an image
with larger dimensions our wallabies a
lot happier now trouble is we're now
serving a bigger image file to everyone
whether they need it or not and that's
going to result in a terrible experience
on a slow Network especially you know on
a smaller screen with lower resolution
the problem with the plain old image
source attribute is that it only gives
one URL for one image what if you want
to provide alternative files for the
same image so the browser can choose the
best option for the viewport size and
device capabilities source set to the
rescue here we added a source set
attribute to our image element the
syntax here simply means that the
browser should choose the higher
resolution wallaby 2x jpg for a high DPI
display or the lower resolution wallaby
1x jpg otherwise the 1x 2x syntax is
called a pixel density descriptor and if
we check from the dev tools using
emulation mode for a 1x device you'll
see that only the 1x image has been
loaded nice wallaby by the way
I've added a 1x descriptor after the 1x
image source but that's the default
different screens have different pixel
densities more or less dots of color per
square inch the physical pixels and the
more dots per inch the higher resolution
the display and the greater the pixel
density so standard laptop and desktop
monitors are regarded as being 1x
displays whereas devices such as high
spec laptops and phones can be 2 X or
more every day there are more and more
new screens with different pixel
densities you can check this from the
dev tools console by looking at the
device pixel ratio for your display here
the device pixel ratio is 1.75 for my
monitor and now I'm using remote
debugging for my phone with the dev
tools and you can see that the device
pixel ratio there is 3 you can find out
more about pixel density by following
the link below the video what if the
browser doesn't support the source
that attribute that's not a problem the
source set attribute is ignored and the
image is loaded in the usual way using
the source attribute here I'm opening
the page in Firefox where the source set
attribute is still behind a flag and
you'll see the One X version is
downloaded the default from the source
attribute turn on the flag reload and
presto you can see the source set
attribute in action source set can also
be used with width units for a browser
there's a catch-22 when it comes to
choosing which image to download the
browser needs to know the dimensions of
each image but it can't know that
without downloading each image to check
enter the Mighty W unit the W unit tells
the browser the width of each image
thereby enabling the browser to choose
the right image to retrieve depending on
the screen pixel density and the
viewport size think about it if you have
a browser window sized at say 500 pixels
wide on a 2x display an image 1000
pixels wide that's 2 times 500 will be
adequate for any display size in that
window the point is that we're enabling
the browser to make the right choice of
image since at runtime the browser knows
the screen size and pixel density but
not the image size later you'll see how
to work with image display sizes that
are less than the full width of the
viewport now you might be wondering why
width and not height well width covers
most use cases but there has been some
discussion of introducing an H unit and
for the responsive obsessives among you
follow the link below the video